[Musica]
larini
tali materie
[Musica]
nel cielo atellana
no perché
[Musica]
da scoprire
tutti
[Musica]
ciao amici riconoscete la mia voce
scommetto che qualcuno c'è riuscito
subito sono proprio io
anita sono qui per raccontarvi una
grande storia la storia dei miei viaggi
nell'universo e di come sono diventata
una bambina magica perciò pop corn alla
mano e mettetevi pure comodi dato che
posso iniziare
vediamo da qui
tutto comincia ben verta la cittadina
dove sono cresciuto
certo non proprio la capitale del
divertimento ma sicuramente un luogo
tranquillo e circondata dal verde
[Musica]
no
le mie giornate iniziavano a scuola
insieme ai compagni e alle mie amiche
del cuore varcato il cancello ci
salutavamo sempre con un grande sorriso
stampato in viso sempre che qualche sla
in volante non ci avesse colpito prima
poi iniziavano le elezioni scienze
storia geografia lingue straniere
mi sono sempre data da fare seguendo con
attenzione così che i compiti a casa
risultassero più facili e veloci e anche
in modo da guadagnare tempo per riuscire
a giocare con i miei amici del parco
poi però ho iniziato ad avere una strana
sensazione come se
lezioni a scuola compagni amichetti del
parco e il poco tempo libero che mi
restava però la solita routine
quotidiana che si ripeteva ancora e
ancora
sembrava che il tempo non scorresse più
[Musica]
finché una sera al parco successe una
cosa che mi avrebbe cambiato per sempre
[Musica]
ciao kiky ciao come state
che bello rivederli mi siete mancati
d'auto scusate ma oggi avere un sacco di
compiti da fare
cli chi ti vedo un po che cicciottello
zip
non è che hai mangiato troppo questo
bosco è davvero fantastico così
rilassante stare qui con voi
[Musica]
cos'è questa ruzza
ma non posso crederci sembra che una
stella cadente si sia schiantata proprio
qui vicino o no chi chi potrebbe essere
pericoloso ferma non andare là non
correre aspettami
[Musica]
quando non darla
beh
dottor aspetta fermo lì arrivo a
prenderti
[Musica]
mi ha fatto preoccupare ma
si no
[Musica]
ma che cos'è questo posto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
ehi
[Musica]
se nessuno
dai vieni fuori non essere timido
[Musica]
ehi ma tu chi sei esattamente quindi sei
tu che hai fatto tutto questo baccano
hai fatto spaventare i miei amici sai
[Musica]
dai non fare così non volevo
rimproverarti pensa che oggi abbiamo
entrambi trovate il nuovo amico non
credi sei proprio simpatico beh amico
cristallo misterioso è davvero tardi per
me devo tornare a casa
16 di rimanere da queste parti posso
venire e salutarti domani ma ma che fai
vuoi venire con me
spero solo che mio padre non si arrabbi
dai andiamo
non so cosa dire al papa
ma io sento che già ti voglio bene
ho deciso
da oggi
[Musica]
sarebbe questo quindi il pianeta terra
nel prossimo episodio
va via da qui
[Musica]
come ridicole viaggiatori stellari
credono di potermi mettere in difficoltà
[Musica]
[Applauso]